what what them into this video playing
the Queen trapper must be a conscious
there may be exchanged Queens quickly
and it's the French a good way to
exchange Queens quickly I don't know
let's see what is staying carefully
considered is t4 leading to a queen trap
ok I want to a salon somewhat strategic
position ya hear this is a crazy game
but yeah if i take it I don't want that
yeah it can take care take you for then
the screen g4s is leading to to a real
mess so this is more more positionally
more strategically founded ok Bishop f5
maybe just now let's make sure there's
nothing happening on b5 like taking
Queenie to check ins and stuff can can
happen ok yeah well here after 97 12-6
son the queen is not not really a big
big problem or big nuisance
yeah everything considered Knight f6
Bishop f5 would be would be nice if I
get get this in yeah yeah Bishop f5 nice
got rookie one I don't really know if I
want dad like Bishop f5 takes takes rook
e1 check maybe better better castle for
us Bishop g5 here i have also 96 all
night f5 okay so he just allows Bishop
f5 without any particular problems nice
i want to get of course his important
d3m attacking bishop exchanged I mean I
to before him
95 if I can take 94 maybe then f6 let's
not spend too much time on it so rare
occurrence that I actually am ahead on
the clock and that should not sure this
this time advantage maybe I'm
maneuvering myself into a somewhat
awkward pinned situation here five it's
a bit it's not not so great you actually
with the rook and you're threatening f3
I will f 3 f g 5 so that's not not so
bad f3 g5 Scott no decent squares for
the Queen ok let's see so here night see
if I may be a 5 a-5 first it's not bad
night Bishop e3 that's night c4 it does
not really have a great square for it
oops really you really would allow me to
take it on a three damaging the pawn
structure like that seems seems to be
this Knight c3 actually very funny move
let's do that it's quite nice takes
Knight xe3 so I have damage to spawn
structure and while the King the king
position I guess the king is not amused
how do I get get at the Qingdao queen
bee six nights a fire or something like
that or maybe queen e 7 a-3 this is
actually a better route maybe start mean
I wonder could be six here maybe Queen B
6 as Queen B one that's coming yeah it's
at least it's at least good for black
maybe maybe I could have done stun it
even even better but it's it's not not
bad at all I wonder a 3 and 9 p-5 not be
five immediately maybe that's Queen d2
okay let's get a 3 into the mix
really this was so easy to play age h5
immediately maybe but what is he doing
now can I not that I cannot take it and
where I can go here at can go here and
then then the night coming to c 4
wow really kewley kind of channel that
is there really no threat but that's
hard to believe maybe there is no threat
hmm I don't have a chick here
and you will take hear you hmm there's
really no way to get it get at the king
hmm
I don't even see a movie at the moment
that's not good time warning sometimes
it's strange game that we play him I
really couldn't couldn't find them
couldn't find made or anything check no
i'm just a pawn down here with Queens
being traded hmm amazing I really didn't
didn't find find a win as bad as it
looked it's still not totally easy for
white but still strange as I certainly
have fun have mr. something good but at
the moment I'm really not sure what it
was plain sorry gras our head why would
you offer me it wrong strange yeah i
don't i don't really know it still is
set an interesting position I know I
must I must agree to draw if you want it
really badly I can play h5 though maybe
maybe I can do it I had the F porn hmm
the f porn the f porn check
okay what the game I really don't know
what's going on here don't check and
take here and David then then he's got
no GF check okay still still on this can
check white forfeits on time what I had
53 100th of a second yeah well I don't
know this was totally crazy I really
don't know I really don't like to take
draws in those kind of unclear positions
maybe I really must take it check around
here now yes the f porn I didn't really
realize he has the F porn but it still
seems to be okay then no white is
winning c3 would win here yeah yeah c3
would win c3a to Andrew k7m I rock him
they have okay we both had 20 seconds so
it's a but hip like his back better even
why I broke f7 I overlooked drooped f7
look f7 is just good this is this is
losing but due to fa mf8 chan yeah well
talk about a crazy game yeah this is
probably should end in the drawer night
and five is better and now no I meant
yeah
I have the people King g6 is a draw yeah
what what can you do the computer is of
course a beast here and we just were
gambling here at the end at the end why
this winning yeah after this I am
winning or I can promote but he can take
me to and win the game but okay we both
at 0 time on the clock yeah I hope you
enjoyed it was a fun fight at least
thanks for watching